مشاهدينا بالعوده الى حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اوفيدا عن هجوم بصواريخ على وسط
مدينه دونتسك ادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرحى
ومعنى من موقع الهجوم نور الدين الدغير
مراسلنا في
اخبرنا ما الذي حصل نور الدين
نعم حسنا نحن هنا وسط مدينه دونيس المشهد
واضح سقوط احدى الصواريخ بهذه المنطقه ادى
الى احتراق كامل لهذه الحافله التي كانت
تقل ركاب واحدث الصاروخ حفره عميقه
نشاهدها بعد هذه الحافله بالاضافه الى
اصابه العديد من السيارات هذا الهجوم ادى
الى سقوط قتلى وكذلك الى سقوط جرحى لحد
الساعه غير معروف عدد القتلى الذين تم
انتشالهم لكن كما نشاهد هنا احدى جتامين
او جثث القتلى الملقيه هنا على الارض لم
يتم نقلها لحد الساعه كذلك وجود سياره
الاسعاف في هذا المكان وتم نقل العديد من
الجرحى فيما تمت معالجه بعض المصابين هنا
في هذا المكان بحسب المعلومات المتوفره
لدينا من السلطات المحليه هنا تعرضت وسط
المدينه الى اربع هجمات بالصواريخ تم
اعتراض ثلاثه منها من قبل الدفاعات الجويه
في مدينه دنيات لكن احدى هذه الصواريخ لم
يتم اعتراضها ما ادى الى سقوطها بهذه
المنطقه واحدات هذه الخسائر هنا لابد كذلك
من الاشاره الى ان احدى الصواريخ كذلك
سقطت في منطقه هذه المنطقه التي توجد كذلك
بالقرب من مركز المدينه لحد الساعه لا
توجد معلومات لكن كما اشرت حسن
ضمائر شده الضمائر الذي احدثته القذيفه
التي سقطت هنا تبدو واضحه المعالم باحتراق
الكامل لهذه الحافله التي كانت تقل الركاب
بالاضافه الى الدمار الذي احددته فيه عدد
من المنازل التي توجد بهذه المنطقه وهذا
يبدو انه حال يوميه خاصه خلال الايام
اليومين الماضيين كنا نشهد سقوط العديد من
القذائف واستهداف العديد من المناطق هنا
في مدينه دنيتك واطرافها شكرا لك نور
الدين الدغير من دونيتسك